welcome back we're halfway done and
works every year here is a woman a
beautiful and talented actress who won
an Oscar for Annie Hall
ladies and gentlemen Diane Keaton
well I you know The Crying Game is a
love story about people who are
frequently called deviant people who
live marginally people who don't seem to
pass the test of being labeled normal
now one of its great traits is that it
forces us to question what's so great
about being labeled normal and it
hauntingly reminds us that love any kind
of love comes and goes in a very
wonderful way that we can't really hold
on to so obviously The Crying Game is an
outsider nobody expected much from it
and I think it's very exciting that the
Academy the press and the public did not
overlook the fourth nominee for Best
Picture The Crying Game
a Best Actor nominee of sports a former
nominee for best
actress Robert Downey jr. and out free
water
tonight we are presenting the award for
outstanding achievement in sound you
know I find it kind of ironic that after
spending a year playing the guy was the
king of silent films that were like
presenting the word for sound like well
this year the talking pictures seem to
dominate the category Robert oh well
it's it's an honor just to be dominated
huh now the nominee is for sound and
they are Terry Porter Mel Metcalfe David
J Hudson and doc Cain for Aladdin Kevin
O'Connell Rick Klein and Bob Eva for a
few good men Chris Jenkins Doug Hemphill
Mark Smith and Simon K for the last of
the Mohicans Don Mitchell Frank a
Montano Rick heart and Scott D Smith for
under siege less special burn poor dick
Alexander and Rob young for Unforgiven
and the Oscar for sound goes to Chris
Jenkins Doug Hempel Mark Smith and Simon
K Vlasic Mohicans
we were completely taken by surprise we
want to thank the members of the Academy
for recognizing us it's a collective
effort we'd like to thank our partner
Paul Massey who's not here tonight lawn
bender and his crew from sound deluxe
our composers Randy Trevor Daniel Lanois
and most of all very importantly Michael
Mann who has worked so hard has given
all of his efforts to really paying
attention to the contribution sound can
make to pictures we are eternally
grateful and would like to thank him
personally thank you very much thank you
before the fifth nominated song I'd like
you to give a nice hand to our Academy
award-winning conductor bill Conti and
the Academy Award orchestra ladies and
gentleman you've done a great job once
again